an explosive new expose by chris ruffo
reveals how teachers in portland oregon
are preparing students now
not to be productive citizens but to be
revolutionaries
rufo writes the political education
programs in portland area
districts constitute a training ground
for child soldiers
this is not hyperbole some of those
active and violent anarchist groups in
portland are run by teenagers
and dozens of minors were arrested in
last year's riots
now here's a glimpse of the violence
that portland's child
soldiers wrought last summer a warning
this is graphic
[Music]
please stop
the person you saw kicking the victim in
the head was 14.
joining me now chris ruffo manhattan
institute senior fellow
contributing editor at city journal
chris um
even though portland is about as far
left as any major city can get
why should every american be concerned
across the country about the
indoctrination
going on in the schools there
well portland area schools have adopted
a new philosophy called the pedagogy of
the oppressed which was
originally a marxist theory that came
from brazil as one of their key teaching
frameworks and what you're seeing is
that students are
being told that they need to achieve
critical consciousness about their own
oppression
and then education system needs to be
reoriented towards
achieving liberation achieving
revolution and you see it in every facet
of the schooling
and i think what's most important and
most damning is that not only were
many children arrested during those
riots but actually many portland public
school teachers were arrested
and through my reporting i've shown that
some of these teachers despite being
arrested for violent riots
are still employed by the district
they've doubled and tripled down
on revolutionary rhetoric and that's
exactly what they're pushing
to the youngest people in our society
yeah meanwhile if you ate a hot dog near
the capitol on
january 6 like you could be in solitary
confinement i mean that's the
exaggeration but
you know you're immediately suspect all
right chris
um there's a program called techsmart in
portland that's
i guess supposed to help improve
literacy
for students in in kindergarten through
fifth grade
and i want to show video that you
obtained of one of the
coaches teaching these students
justice fighters you may have heard some
things in the news about people
protesting
and injustices in our country you've
trained for this moment
all year to fight for justice
now is the time to show that you will
fight for justice
chris what does this have to do with
improving literacy
it doesn't but what you've seen is that
the bureaucracy has been totally
ideologized and and submerged in this
ideology and
keep in mind that this teacher is
speaking to elementary school students
uh telling that they need to become
justice fighters telling that they need
to get out into the streets
and fight along with the protesters in
portland and
this same teacher according to witnesses
who observed it
also engaged in essentially george
orwell's two-minute hate program
uh in this public school they allowed
minority teachers to berate white
teachers for 90 seconds
uh in a kind of display of public
apology for your whiteness
uh these are the kind of things that are
happening within the institutions
i have the documents i have the videos
and if it's not in your school district
now
they're pushing to put it everywhere in
the coming years yeah chris this was a
video you say was shown to third grade
students at the beaverton school
district now this is just
outside of portland
one of the most freeing things that
white people can do
or non-poc people actually any human
being on the planet could do right now
is to just say of course i'm racist what
happens when i say of course i'm racist
is what it does is it says oh this is
not a personal or
moral failing this is not because i'm a
bad person this is not because i'm some
evil terrible being
this is because that is the structure of
this society that i've been immersed in
these eight and nine-year-olds are being
told that america is a racist country
and they're racist
really quick chris out of this yeah i
mean i spoke with actually a woman from
iran who said that she grew up in tehran
iran
chanting death to america before school
and she told me that what's happening
the indoctrination of her child
in beaverton public schools reminds her
of what was happening back in iran
they're sending up these red flares to
warn us what's happening in the schools
it should terrify all americans and i
hope that we can come together and push
back
well none of these people should be
employed as teachers period they should
all lose their jobs will they
chris thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else